[Music]
it's a new season and everyone's got to
watch out because now I'm on my a game
I'm looking for the person that can win
the voice that's my job that's what they
hired me to do I am definitely here if I
get a win then nothing to be here at all
I think that every season I'm a threat
to every coach I always want to win it's
fun the beginning of the blind auditions
Adam and I made a pact that we were
going to try to get along be respectful
of each other actually even be kind to
each other
you're not gonna see me being mean to
Blake the season because you know what I
love Blake and I think he's a really
good friend I love you too Adam happy
birthday in case I missed it thank you
have your mother good good good to see
Lincoln I decided we were gonna play
nice so far it's working I'm pretty sure
it won't last
but it's nice it's a breath of fresh air
well done Adam well done
Thank You Blake she did a great job that
was a great pitch thinking you said very
smart things thank you but I think you
got the Rockpile
Thank You Blake there's a really
beautiful gesture that shows me that
it's very sincere hope you're all having
a good day Adam and I decided you know
what let's just put the grudge aside
let's just try to get along let's try to
get along for a season let's root for
each other let's be support for each
other
hi see how that works out so far so good
it's just so cool I look forward to
seeing how your team grows America's
heart will melt that suit fits you great
thank you either way you look extra
handsome have you slimmed down
no I look fantastic I think there's
something weird going on with this Adam
Blake thing and I don't buy it I think
you're handsome Blake I love your new
haircut by the way
Rachel always has a point we're getting
along we're staying out of each other's
way we're being supportive and
complimentary we're gonna kill it with
kindness this year
Blake you win some you lose some good
try buddy I think we'll get along this
entire season you're feeling down I'm
gonna take a ride with you turn him
around I feel good about Adam and oz
relationship this season you always made
me feel better at him
Thank You Adam and I tried to start off
the season getting along and we did for
about a half a day there
this is gonna be good I fight the good
fight every season Wow
get them out can't not hate him now
we're even oh you want to keep going ok
next level that's fine me next level
y'all sit back and wait for the rest
[Music]